the fact-checking at the new yorker is a
legendary
uh position and a process yeah uh
having i had a story written about me by
larissa mcfark back in the day
and went through it were you how was
your checking experience
it was extraordinary because i i think
it was two different people
contacted me and maybe they contacted me
three different times
and you know it was everything from do
you have a bulldog and
can you spell the bulldogs name uh do
you live at this address do you know
this person and
when you're the subject you're kind of
trying to figure out like
who do they talk to and where did this
come from and then
you don't really have the ability to see
the person who said that or where did
you get that from so you kind of get
into this little bit of a dialogue like
what do you mean by that and
did you say this and it felt like it was
like a very um
uh they were trying to get the facts
straight without telling me what the
story would be who the subjects were and
it was actually i felt very good about
it because
the only other time i had that type of
fact checking done was
in wired magazine and the times i've
been in the new york times or since when
i get
mentioned i get mentioned in a story in
the atlantic or new york magazine
and there's no fact checking nobody ever
journalists don't even call you to tell
you don't even give you a heads up
you're going to be in the story now
so things have changed radically i guess
because the budgets don't exist anymore
to do fact checking
yeah the good ones still do and uh you
know
with new york magazine we we have fact
checkers and it
you know but the budget is hard and
people would often ask me like sort of
you know what's what's the secret uh to
the new yorker's fact fact-checking
and you know how do you guys do what you
do and the reality of it is
manpower it's you know they there's a
sort of army of i i think this might be
outdated but when i was there there were
16 17 18
fact checkers who who fact check every
uh every word of
of uh of anything that went in the
magazine even the cartoons
um and and we did go through a fact
checking process
on on the book um book publishers do not
have fact checkers
uh on staff it sort of is um incumbent
on
the writer to choose to have a fact
checker if they want and and i like that
part of the process i would rather
go back to you jason and say here's what
i'm saying here's
sort of why i'm saying it is this is
this right and both a
fix any mistakes and kind of give you or
whoever it is a chance to
you know add some context and and in
some cases sort of add add even more
interesting context my understanding
back then was the fact checkers got paid
like 30 or 40
an hour of the freelancers what does a
fact checker get paid you if you would
take a guess at a new yorker
or a a publication on that scale like a
conversation publication when i
joined per when i joined the company i
was on staff and
i believe i was making something in the
neighborhood of 40 000
a year so you know in new york city it's
you can survive um but uh that was ten
years ago
uh it was worth ten years period uh
right around then
yeah when i came into the workforce in
1993
it was 500 bucks a week i think conde
nast and those kind of places it was 30
thousand so
people who think that these journalists
get paid a lot is
you got a little it literally went up
ten thousand in 15 years
yeah it's it it is um it's a tough
business
unfortunately since we're on this
subject
i think this inside baseball is just
absolutely fantastic and i appreciate
you
delving into it